en ouvrant collectivement les lumières
chaque matin le signal est envoyé à ce
centre de contrôle tenus secrets par
hydro québec
de là on a juste le débit deux centrales
situées à des milliers de kilomètres on
ne veut ni trop produire ni passé
produire pour satisfaire cette demande
est ce que ça veut dire aussi c'est que
la demande peu varié à chaque minute
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'il ya
aux alentours de 30 mille kilomètres de
lignes en fait qui sépare qui acheminent
c'est ce courant entre les centres de
production et les centres de
consommation l'électricité n'arrive pas
en flux régulier sur les lignes de
transport
elle est constamment ajuster à la
demande qui varie selon l'heure et les
saisons prévoir la demande est un
exercice complexe où on doit répondre à
la consommation locale minimiser les
importations et maximiser les
exportations une simple percées de
soleil fait chuter la consommation
un humain n'aurait pas la capacité ou
même plusieurs humain n'aurait pas la
capacité de de gérer la ce qu'on appelle
finement la stabilité du réseau
on veut pas seulement prévoir le pique
qui va avoir lieu
une fois par année on veut on veut
prévoir en tout temps en fait le
comportement du consommateur est
l'institut de recherche d'hydro-québec
au travail à de nouveaux modèles de
prévision en utilisant l'intelligence
artificielle invoke auteurs font partie
de l'équation ne les compteurs
intelligents qui sont installés partout
à grandeur de la province qui sont une
mine d'or pour les modèles
d'optimisation des modèles en trop
d'intelligences artificielles donc on
utilise ces données le pour apprendre
comment les gens se comportent comme ans
lors de la demande évolue c'est bon pour
l'environnement parce que si on a une
meilleure prévision de la mangue on est
en mesure de moins par exemple importer
l'électricité des américains les modèles
de prévision intelligent pourrait
permettre à hydro québec de faire de
grandes économies
d'autant plus que ces modèles continuent
d'apprendre avec visage sur nos
habitudes ici michel marsolais résout
canada montréal